[Música]
a primera vista esta pintura tal vez no
parece algo especial pero es una de las
pinturas más estudiadas en la historia
del arte
se titula las meninas o la familia de
Felipe IV y es una pintura de Diego
Velázquez de 1656 que representa una
escena en la vida de la corte real
española una infanta bien vestida
rechaza un vaso de agua de una criada
mientras que un enano se burla de un
perro otra enana está a su lado mientras
el propio artista posa en el Lienzo dos
personas susurran en el fondo y otra
parece salir de la habitación Y por qué
no habría de hacerlo si parece que no
pasa nada hasta el perro parece aburrido
pero si observa con atención las dos
personas reflejadas en el espejo borroso
del fondo pasados por alto a primera
vista son el rey Felipe IV y la reina
Mariana y parecen cambiar la escena de
una simple representación de la vida
cortesana a un retrato real y con esta
información podemos entender mucho más
el cuadro y por qué ha cautivado al
espectador durante siglos
en primer lugar está el contexto
histórico cuando se pintó las meninas al
final del reinado de Felipe el Imperio
español estaba en decadencia tras sufrir
una derrota en la Guerra de los 30 años
así como dificultades económicas y
políticas
el propio Rey había sufrido también una
desgracia perdió a su primera esposa y a
su único heredero al Trono antes de
volver a casarse
pero la pintura oculta su esfuerzo por
proveer alimentos a la familia incluso
ocultan la edad avanzada del monarca
mediante la difuminación del espejo lo
que sí vemos en el centro geométrico de
la tela brillantemente iluminada por la
luz de la ventana es a la infanta
margarita Teresa única hija legítima del
Rey en ese momento su aspecto brillante
y saludable es una imagen idealizada del
futuro de este imperio en apuros sin
embargo la infanta no es el único foco
de la pintura mediante el uso hábil de
la perspectiva y el tamaño natural de la
obra un Lienzo de 3,18 metros por 2,76
metros Velázquez desdibuja la frontera
entre arte y realidad y crea una
tridimensionalidad la línea entre el
techo y la pared converge hacia la
puerta abierta y crea la percepción del
cuadro como un espacio físico visto
desde la perspectiva del espectador
en este sentido el foco de atención son
el público y el mundo real subrayados
por las tres figuras que miran
directamente al espectador Pero hay otro
punto focal la línea formada por la
iluminación lleva al centro de la pared
posterior al espejo que refleja a la
pareja real y su posicionamiento en
relación con el espectador ha llevado a
toda clase de interpretaciones de la
obra
el espejo podría estar reflejando al rey
y la reina que posan para su retrato o
refleja el Lienzo Y qué opinamos de que
Velázquez nunca pintara El retrato real
aquí aludido podría la pintura en cambio
ilustrar su propia creación con la
incorporación del espejo a la obra
Velázquez elevó el arte de la pintura de
su percepción como un simple oficio a un
esfuerzo intelectual con sus tres puntos
centrales en pugna las meninas captura
el contraste entre el mundo ideal el
real y el reflejado y mantiene la
atención no resuelta entre ellos para
contar una historia más compleja que la
que un espejo pueda reflejar
sigue explorando el mundo del arte y los
artistas con este video sobre la
extraordinaria vida y el arte de la
pintora mexicana Frida Kahlo o descubra
con este video por qué la joven de La
perla de vermir se considera una Obra
maestra de la edad de oro holandesa